the Supreme Court's decision to ban
far-right politician Elias cassidiaris
from this month's election apparently
came as no surprise outside the court
his lawyer announced he was directing
his supporters to a little-known party
that hasn't entered Parliament the
Spartans
I don't personally know the Spartans but
Mr cassidiaris tells me they have been
around for years they include Patriots
professionals members of society
including blue collar workers and I
think it's right that Parliament should
represent all social classes I think as
their common nationalist pedigree that
led Mr casidiaris to this decision
the Supreme Court disqualified him ahead
of a general election last month because
of a felony conviction an Athenian Court
jailed cassidiaris and his fellow MPS
three years ago saying Golden Dawn was a
criminal organization responsible for
dozens of murders and beatings of
immigrants and leftists they were also
self-professed National socialists or
Nazis Golden Dawn entered parliament in
2012 when Greece was cutting public
spending the economy was in a deep
recession and unemployment stood at 25
percent they lost their seats four years
ago as Greece returned to growth for
many people in this country that
suffered from Nazi occupation the very
existence of a far-right party was a
source of deep embarrassment and concern
the Spartans spokesman says his party
has no Nazi affiliation
we are in no way a vehicle for national
socialism we denounce it vigorously we
talk about democracy and Grace is its
birthplace we are an anti-establishment
party aiming towards National rebirth we
want to strengthen Greece's culture
foreign policy and preserve its identity
from the ravages of globalization Golden
Dawn 2 styled itself as an anti-systemic
party coming to replace an old and
self-serving political order messages of
patriotism national identity and honest
dealing resonate in Europe these days
and polls show cassidiaris commands
three percent of the vote enough to make
a triumphant return to Parliament John
saropoulos Al Jazeera Athens